[Musique]
jean marie le pen le président du front
national d'extrême droite et qui fut
candidat à l'élection présidentielle de
1974 revient à la une de l'actualité à
l'occasion d'une curieuse affaire il
assure être l'héritier unique d'un
richissime homme d'affaires hubert
lambert qu'il est mort il ya un mois à
saint cloud et qui lui laisserait la
coquette somme de 3 milliards d'anciens
francs la famille d'hubert lambert
conteste le testament en affirmant que
leurs parents n'était plus en possession
de ses facultés quand il a fait des le
pen ses héritiers du papier bleu et une
cascade de procès en perspective
jean-marie le pen 48 ans breton licencié
en droit actuellement directeur d'une
société d'édition de disques politique
ancien député ancien engagé volontaire
en indochine et en algérie président du
front national hubert lambert 42 ans son
ami disparu était membre du comité
central du front national il était donc
tout acquis aux idées de jean marie le
pen qui l'avait rejoint lors de la
campagne présidentielle de 74 depuis
jean marie le pen et sa femme pierrette
étaient devenus les intimes d'hubert
lambert
[Musique]
je suis le légataire réellement
universel et j'ai agi comme tel depuis
la mort de mon ami je tiens à préciser
d'ailleurs un sujet que si je n'étais
pas un personnage public je ne me
prêterai pas à ses interviews jean-marie
le pen philippe lambert vous accuse
presque d'avoir en quelque sorte drogué
hubert lambert qui aurait ainsi rédigé
ce fameux testament votre faveur sous
l'effet de calmants monsieur je ne
répondrai pas aux accusations de
monsieur philippe lambert cette affaire
est devant la justice il appartiendra
monsieur philippe lambert de faire la
preuve de ses assertions et à moi d'en
tirer des conclusions des conclusions
qui s'imposent dans tous les domaines
madame le pen vous avez assisté en
quelque sorte hubert lambert dans ses
derniers instants ou du moins dans ces
dernières semaines comment était-il on
est prêt mais également c'est sûr mais
il était malade comme il était
d'habitude il était aussi du site que
d'habitude en tout cas voici la photo du
père lambert décimant lambert le jour de
son mariage une photo qui n'était même
pas aller chercher chez le photographe
on dit même qu'il aurait interrompu son
voyage de noces pour aller rejoindre sa
mère ici dans leur hôtel particulier de
saint cloud ici où habite également le
cousin qui conteste la validité du
dernier testament en présence de son
avocat m gref cette opération montée par
monsieur l'appel me paraît absolument
scandaleuse mon cousin
german vers lambert était un garçon que
j'ai fort bien connu puisque nous avons
habité pendant de nombreuses années
ensemble c'est un garçon qui
malheureusement est avait une totale
absence de volonté il était
essentiellement influençable et se
trouvait en plus un sujet être là
pouvoir être flatté
il était disons le malade par tous les
traitements et tous les tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient être absorbées comme
médicaments et autres produits et il est
certain que cette ce pauvre ce pauvre
garçon a été
à la fin de sa vie victimes en somme de
tout ce qu'il a pu de cette vie
absolument anormal qu'il monnaie il a
selon vous été influencé somme paraît
incontestable
3 milliards de centimes des [ __ ] ci
après les procès et les prélèvements du
fisc jean marie le pen en conservait
toujours le bénéfice cela fait encore
une belle somme ne serait il pas tenté
alors de mettre cet argent au service de
son parti
en fait si vous voulez j'ai consacré ma
vie à la politique par conséquent il est
bien évident que les moyens qui sont à
ma disposition sont aussi à la
disposition de mes idées c'est normal
[Musique]